Welcome to A.V. Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts Alan, Spy, and Brent will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
Hey everyone, it is Spy, Brent is still working on Satya's castle, adding a few
rooms this week.
He's brushing up on his carpenter skills.
So I am here with Global Warming and Walmart.
So Global Warming is like the new Brent, he's on every episode now.
So let me start with Walmart.
Tell us a little bit about where you are, who you're from, something interesting.
And let the three, actually there's two people here, let the other listener know what's
going on.
Sure.
First of all, thanks for having me here.
It's a pleasure.
I've been listening to the podcast for quite a while.
You are an inspiration for me.
I'm Valmir.
I'm from Brazil originally, but I'm speaking from Barcelona.
I'm a QA engineer.
I've been working as a QA for the past 20 years, almost 21 now.
And yeah, super excited to be here and share a bit of my experience.
Talk about what happened in 2005 and see.
2025.
I can't remember 2005.
2025 and see what's going to happen in 2026.
Cool.
Well, cool.
Thank you.
Glad to have you here.
Global.
I'm not Brent here again.
And hopefully this time, finally fixed like the last Audio Kings.
I think you're a little too close to your microphone, getting a little bit of pop.
But other than that, you're great.
Okay.
Yeah.
The last Kings.
We're still filling out the final, final, final, the final, final version, too, on
the fly.
So now, yeah, last time the audio was messed up again.
So this time, I hope for everything.
Should be awesome.
Just blame it on the producer.
That's me.
It's fine.
Well, we've done.
This is our 234th episode of A.B. testing doesn't count the A.B., A.B. three for
threes we did.
So a lot of episodes and they're all my fault.
That's where we're at.
Cool.
Well, I'm glad to have you both here.
So Barcelona, but originally from Germany and Germany.
Did I get that right or for Austria?
I'm originally from Brazil.
Brazil.
Oh, Brazil.
I'm the German.
You're the German.
OK, you're all over the place.
All right.
OK.
What do I know?
This is like I've heard last week's I had Lena on and I welcomed her like back.
Thanks coming back.
And she says, actually, I've never been here.
You were on my podcast and spy.
You're just an idiot.
So yeah, yes, it happened.
So I stuff flies over my head.
Well, I'm glad to have you both here.
This is something Brent and I have done for the last.
This will be the 11th time we've done this, I believe, because we had our ten
year anniversary last year.
And we'd like to take some time in the last episode of the year to just reflect a little
bit on industry things, personal things, things that happened in twenty twenty five.
And then we'll take some time at the end to talk a little bit about what we see
coming.
And maybe if we feel like it, make a few bold predictions.
So does that work for you, too?
Perfectly.
All right.
So let's I'm not going to start.
How about that?
Valner, why don't you just talk a little bit about like what were some what were some
things that interested you in twenty twenty five, whether there are podcasts or books
or music or movies and we can kind of well, we can jump around a little bit here,
but you don't have to do them all.
But talk a little bit about things that you found interesting in twenty twenty
five.
Yeah.
So one book that I read in twenty twenty five, which I found quite interesting was
Tidy First, Personal Experience and Empirical in Empirical Software Design.
It was the last book from Kent Beck.
It's a very small book that talks about software design.
And I found it very interesting because the year before I had read a philosophy
of software design by John Osterhout, which is a professor at the standard
for a university and kind of Kent Beck kind of got inspired by reading his book
and decided to write this one, which talks about software design and talks about
complexity and talks about what and like the name is Tidy First with a
question mark in the end, and he explains things like when you when you
were working in a software problem, if you are going to make a change in the
software, like a behavioral change in the software before and then you tied it
after or if you have to tie it first because the code might be too messy
and then you have to tie it first to then make it easier for you to make
the change or if you were just going to make the change and you are not
going to tie it immediately after, but you are going to create something
for a backlog of tidings or maybe it's a piece of code that you are going to
touch it just once and never more.
And then you are not never going to tie it, but it's a quite interesting
book because I read Refactoring from Martin Fowler quite a while ago.
And this one Tidy First, it's like a small refactorings that you can do
while you were working in a piece of code that allows you to create
software in a very sustainable way and he mentions some very interesting
things like about the cost of software and he says that the cost of software
is approximately equal to the cost of the biggest change that you have
to make in the software and that the biggest change that you have to
make the software is very related to how much coupled the software is or
not. So the cost of software is approximately equal to the coupling
of the software and then he explains that if you are able to decouple
the software while you are building it and tidying it, it allows you
to build software in a more sustainable manner.
So this is fascinating and if you like three years ago, one of my
predictions, right off chat, came out, one of my year end predictions
was that the ability to read code would become more important than
the ability to write and we're already seeing that, but I think
this is more important.
I think people that can get design and refactoring people that
can take whatever AI generates and then turn that into something
that's maintainable and scalable and understands how to do the
things that maybe the LLMs and pattern matching can't do.
That's, I think, going to become, I'm already in predictions, I think
I'm probably not the first person to say this, that's going to
become a more important skill.
Like I think this is actually a good book to read, especially
in the days of AI and AI generated code is how do you take
this code that, you know, AI generates code that works and
sometimes works really well, but it needs some caressing and I
think if you have the knowledge on how to refactor, how to
tidy first, how and when to tidy and how to recognize where
these costs are going to come up, that's going to be a
really valuable skill.
Well, I don't think AI for codes going away anytime soon, so
I think these skills are going to become more important.
It's prompts and I hate the term prompt engineering, it's
prompts and then intelligent refactoring and design based
on, you know, it's metal level programming.
You're getting like the code's free, making it sustainable and
shippable and scalable code.
That's the new skill, maybe.
And I think when I prompt, I'm always thinking about this
kind of sorcerer standing in a field reading from a spell
book and then just finding the right combination of wounds
and spells for something to do its bidding.
But what my experience as a code gen user is definitely
that besides making it work, a big part is making it more
tidy and throwing things away.
Like the gen AI tends to generate much more than you
need usually.
And then the skill is not like, or like part of tidying
up is also like throwing things away and knowing what
things are obsolete and finding out how.
Yeah, there's some critical thinking and design skills
that are just, the importance is rising incredibly.
Yeah, and I think you touched the point that is quite
interesting in my opinion, which is the importance of
reading code becoming more and more valuable nowadays, which
is something that everyone likes to write the code, but
then you get a pile of pull requests in the waiting for
code review column and instead of someone that is
free because just finished a piece of work, review your
code. They prefer to pick another task to start working
on. But then if we think about like Kanban, we are
creating a big bottleneck in the waiting for review.
What I'm saying is I think the ability to review code
is so much more important than the ability to generate
code. I'm saying that even worse. I would say that
10 years ago when you're writing the code, like
the ability to review and evaluate code.
I myself, for example, I love reading code. I learned
so much from code written by others, but that's, I
don't know if that's like with every developer out
there. I pretty much like getting some code of
someone else to review and give feedback,
constructive feedback that can make the code better
and move it further than picking up the next task
just because coding is fun as well.
Right. And I think that skill is a good skill.
And my prediction is going to become more important.
Cool. I'm going to come back to the other
questions, but I like that. Global Forming,
what book has inspired you this year?
Books this year. I must admit I have not read
many technical books.
Does that mean technical?
Yeah, but I've started by accident. I'm sometimes
visiting the local library with my son. And
after he's like picked his 15 books, it's like
I'm skimming through the shelves looking for
some English language work. And I found more of
Terry Pratchett stuff, like some Discworld
things, some like Long Earth things. Very nice.
It's very, very entertaining.
I tried to read Discworld. I don't think I'm
smart enough to understand it. I don't know.
I couldn't get into it. That's all I'm saying.
It's like, I'll give it another shot.
So cool. Anything else from the book side?
I'll go through my list.
I can mention another book that I read this
year, which was quite nice. And I even
emailed the author asking him if he would
write the second edition, which was Digital
Code, the book that talks about the history
of Bitcoin from the start until 2014. So
more than 10 years passed since he finished
the book. And I asked him if he was going
to launch a second edition. And unfortunately,
there's no second edition coming up, but
it was such a nice reading because it was
written by, I think he's a journalist. And
so he got like many information about like
the origins and everyone that was involved
in the email lists that was from the
people that were building Bitcoin itself.
It's a fascinating story. I am a person
that pretty much like this cryptocurrencies
thing. So I even invest in some of them.
So it was nice getting some of the
history behind it to back you up when you
are like really investing in that kind of
stuff.
Super interesting. I'll talk a little bit
more about investing later. But I will talk.
So I, as our other listener knows, because
you only have three and two of them are
here. I went on a long hike last summer.
And as you know, from previous podcasts, I
read a lot of books on tech and leadership.
And I told myself I would not read any
while I was hiking, but I was going to
read fiction. And I did. I read so on
the trail. I read four books. I read the
entire Brandon Sanderson Mistborn trilogy.
And then I read the latest prequel to
the Hunger Games. Quick read because one
of my old coworkers recommended it. So
I read those all fun reads. Very cool
to get through. And then I sent my
Kindle home because I was hiking too
longer in the day and days got
shorter. Since I got back, one of our
listeners suggested this actually
got me this book. And I read this book
called Outlive by there it is for
people. Great, great podcast. Book
called Outlive by Peter Attia. And it
is because I got back from the trail
and I went right away. I went to the
doctor to get my blood test and and
to get a baseline. And I am I have
like the health, the blood of a
20 year old now, now that I'm 25.
And which is really good. But then
this book called Outlive is actually
really interesting talks about
because both my parents, my dad
especially had a long decline before
he passed. And Peter Attia talks about
the idea of a health span versus a
lifespan. We may live to 90. But at
the last 15 years, we're just kind
of nah, like I don't want to live
that way. I want to have a long
health span. I want to be going
strong until I'm pretty much dead.
And just a lot of a lot of things
he talks about and he breaks it down
into not just the physical, but how
mental health is really important
for your health span. And I truly
believe that as well. So a lot of
head nodding, a lot of good
information. I feel good that I'm
already doing a lot of stuff on
that he talks about doing in the
book. I don't know how long I'm
going to live. I probably got at
least five years left, maybe
longer. But anyway, really good
read for me. I recommend that
one.
This is this is in my list. There
is a podcast that I watch that I
listen to, which is about
investments. And they always have
guests. And they always ask the
guests for books
recommendations. They ask about
like books about their field, a
book about the free theme and
also a book to to burn a book
that you would never read to
recommend for you not to read.
And recently, someone recommended
outlive. And then I, I also
want to leave as much as
possible in a healthy way. So
it's in my list to read it.
Oh, very, very cool. And actually,
I want to go back to why don't we
go into podcasts? There's books.
Let's talk about podcasts
listen to. And I'm going to
start because I don't know
which I shall ask you a vommer
which which podcast was that
was it called?
It's called Market Makers. It's
from from some some some guys
that work in investments in
Brazil. The podcast is in
Portuguese and they
basically I won't listen to it
then. Yeah, but it's it's a
really interesting one for for
a person who wants to invest
because they talk from with
people who are like investors
for a very long time. And they
talk with people from politics
and from the left from the
right. So it's a very broad
podcast and it's like less
very much lots of lessons
learned listening to it. It
was the podcast that in my
on my Spotify. It was the one
that I listened the most last
year. And this is one of them
they have like many podcasts
Market Makers is one of them
then they have one called
Crypto Never Sleeps, which is
more into the crypto world
than there is Risk Brazil,
which is talks about all the
risks that we have in my
country. And there's even one
called Sports Market Makers
where they talk about finance
finance in the in the sports
industry, which is quite
fascinating. Very interesting.
And I want to segue that
because another I listened to a
lot of podcasts on the trail
as well. And I started
listening to again,
recommendations from another
awesome hiker out of this
kind of this concept exists
in Germany or in Barcelona
or or Brazil, but the
concept of fire financial
independent retire early. I'm
not so care don't care so
much about the retire early
part, but in America,
especially where health care
is a privilege, not a right.
And we don't care about
old people. There is a
community of folks that they
call called fire if they
want achieve financial
independence, how much do
you need to say focus on
saving versus like I worked
at Microsoft back in the day
when everybody blew all
their stock options to buy
boats and really expensive
cars. And I in the
hand, I'm a little frugal
tried to save my money.
So I'm in a position now
where I have financial
independence, meaning I have
enough money. I don't need
to work again. Obviously,
I like working and I want
to have talked about the
story of the podcast
before. But these are more
personal finance podcast,
things like I think the
one I like the most is
called choose Fi. There's
another one called stacking
Benjamin's, which are about
personal finance. How do
you what strategies should
you use to make sure you're
saving enough money and
make sure you're both the
tax planning and with and
with ways to save money
and invest it safely that
you can get to a stage
where you can live off of
your your savings
indefinitely. And one
other book I read after
getting back from trails
read this is a book
called Die with Zero,
meaning good tying it into
Peter at his work on
Outlive is rather than
have all my savings left
when I die, have almost
no savings left when I
die. Not that I wouldn't
leave money to children,
but transfer money to
them early when they may
need it because you in
the U.S. tax because
we can give them a big
chunk of money every
year. And the goal is
to not like if you
have you've saved this
money for your retirement
or for hiking the PCT
or other trails, whatever
you want to do is you
should actually spend
that on great experiences
you want to have because
the things you want to do
now, I think I want to
do now. I may not be
able to do what I'm in
my sixties or seventies
or eighties. So I want
to focus on and die
with zero talks about
bucketing and doing
like like there's things
that you know you won't
have the health to do
when you're 80 do them
now. Don't wait. And
spending money on
experiences versus things
which I really like. So
those things really stuck
out to me as well. So
I heard about this one
as well. I heard about
this one as well. And
actually it was a
recommendation from a
friend who was one of
the people that inspired
me a few years ago to
start investing. And he
was this person that
thinks in the long run.
And recently he read
this book and started
changing a little bit
his way of investing.
It's not really in my
book list this one yet,
but I heard about it
and it's a really
interesting topic to
read about, I think.
Yeah. It's funny for
my own growth. Something
I thought about before,
but never really got
into the podcast. The
podcast is super
helpful. Global warming.
Yeah. What resonates
with me is like the
concept of being rich
in terms of an old
book, Fabek, saying
being rich is kind of
not like in terms of
money, but in terms of
like how many months
can you survive without
any income and fire,
I guess, then being the
goal of I am in month
so rich that I get to
my end of life, right?
And still have enough
to live the life I
want. So being rich
is about being
sustainable rich.
Right. Well, it's not
obvious. I don't even
know what being rich
means. That's the
definition there. Being
rich is being you have
your way of life and
you can sustain your
way of life without
any further income for
three months. That's
your being rich times
three. Well, yeah, the
idea with fire is
that generally up the
heuristic is and
because the market
changes every year and
you can't predict is,
you know, four percent
and you can live on
four percent of your
savings. You can live
indefinitely. I'm
pulling way more than
four percent from my
savings right now
because I'm not
working and I have,
you know, children in
college. So a little
more expensive, but
and, you know, depends
what the market does
and who knows what
it's going to do.
So, um, but
regarding,
depending on where I
choose to live.
Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead.
We got regarding other
podcasts. What I
started listening to
I'm like politically
I'm very left leaning.
I would say, um,
though I'm also like
very lazy and also
kind of nihilistic
and hedonistic, but
still, um, what I
started listening to
is like the New York
Times opinion podcast.
Oh, I was started.
What's called interesting
times, uh, which
has like many kind of
extremist and right
on conservative and
Republican guests and
topics. And I don't
really like the people
who are on these
podcasts, but still
like interesting to
listen to. Yeah,
it's, it can be
interesting to hear
where they're coming
from for sure. But,
uh, it's as you
both know, as, as, as
uh, I think apparent
to the entire world,
uh, politics in the
U S is in a very
strange and unsettling
place right now.
What, what, what,
what stuck a bit is
like, for example,
JD Vance talking
about like being a
Christian and talking
about loving your next
and your kin and your
neighbors. And in the
same sentence talking
about, yeah, I guess
I'm also like an
American and need to
like, uh, shoot at
foreigners who are like
coming over the borders
and these kinds of
things, right? How, how
do you, yeah, that's,
it's strange. Yeah.
This kind of dissociation.
Yeah, let's not get
into that. Right.
We are talking about,
Oh, let's, Oh, can we
talk about your failures?
Like, because I was,
I was listening to the
last year's episode and
I thought you kind of
don't really got a
check mark on all your
like things you want.
Oh, you know what?
Yeah. Right.
I, um, I'm going to
let you guys talk and
I'm going to look that
up and, and, and just,
uh, give me, give me a
moment here. Uh, so while
I do that, so any other
podcasts, new podcasts
you want to talk about
before we get into,
uh, entertainment.
Okay. Let's talk about
entertainment. Uh, what,
uh, do theaters still
exist? I don't know,
but, uh, but we don't
talk about that. Uh,
movies, movies you
liked, you hated TV
shows you liked, you
hated. Uh, I have a
couple that I'll add,
but let's hear from
you guys first. Um,
anything from the
entertainment world could
be music, movies, TV
shows. What, what were
you, what would you
recommend from 2025?
Hmm. Music related in
my years in review from
Spotify. Arctic Monkeys
was the, the, the band
that I listened the
most. And I pretty much
like, like this in the
rock style. I pretty
much like also cage,
the elephant highly
recommended. I know cage,
the elephant cage, the
elephant. I remember
when I was once
watching a TV show,
don't remember which
one I think it was
Lucifer. And in the
entrance of one of the
episodes, there was one
of these musics from
cage, the elephant
before I knew them. And
after I got to know
cage, the elephant,
I recognized that the
music was from them. I
pretty much like it and
highly recommend for the
people who never listen
to it.
That's very cool. Yeah.
I like cage, the
elephant. I haven't
listened to them in a
while though, but I
know about them. How
about you global
vermin? What's on your
music list?
Well, I guess the most
recent thing was just
kind of odd. Somebody,
I guess from the, from
the album list, like
infected mushroom has
like a nice, uh, I
don't know infected
mushroom. Infected
mushroom has a nice
like cover song of the
pretender, which is,
which, which is, which
works very hard. Um, but
yeah, my, my, my
Spotify list is full of
like, uh, like this
year was mostly like
gaming soundtracks.
So this year saw the
release of, um, uh,
expedition 33. Um, and
the, the, the, like
Lumiere Lumiere, the
sound like one of the
soundtracks, um, is
amazing. And I just
listened to that a
lot. And because like
I had an intern this
year in the office
and he was very much
into gaming as well.
We were listening to
like Spotify gaming
soundtracks all the
year. So, uh, risk of
rain soundtrack and
command and conquer
soundtrack, um, these,
these kinds of things.
Um, so this is what I
recommend. Go, go check
out, I guess the, the,
the, um, go to a song
would be how much, how
much from command and
conquer, whatever
version you find
orchestral, it works.
Yeah. I, um, so most
of my Spotify list is
from, um, the trail
where I listened to,
I didn't listen to
music a lot that, um,
sometimes listen to
podcast. I listened to
an audio book. Uh, I
listened to the hail
Mary project, going back
to books. I forgot
about that one, which
is by the same author
as the Martian. I
thought it was pretty
good. There's a movie
coming out, um, with
Ryan Gosling is the
lead. So I'm not sure
how I feel about that,
but whatever. Um, I
listened to like my
end of year wrapped is
so funny. I listened to
a lot of like emo
pop punk, like a lot
of, a lot of green
day, a lot of, uh,
bad religion, a lot
of just, just that,
that kind of, that
kind of genre, some
social distortion,
et cetera. And then I
listened to, um, the
soundtrack to, uh,
Hedwig and the angry
inches was one of my
favorite musicals, like,
like 20 times. Um, it,
so I'm into musicals.
I liked, especially
some of the new ones
coming out. So since
we were talking about
music, a movie that
I watched last week,
which I pretty much
liked because I watched
the first one was the
new one from the
Joker, uh, which is
a musical with lady
Gaga. Oh, such a
nice continuation of
the movie. Yeah. I
don't know if you
have seen it, but I
highly recommend it.
And if you haven't
watched the first
Joker, you have to
watch the first one
before you watch the,
the one with lady
Gaga. It's a very,
very nice movie. I
heard very lots of
critiques about the
movie, but I think
it's because many
people that watch
movies, they don't
like musicals. I
pretty much like it
because I love music
and so highly
recommend it as well.
And regarding Spotify
metrics, like my, my
big vanity metric is
like the listen minutes.
I'm a very, I'm a
Spotify power user.
Like I'm the reason
everybody's prices go
up here.
Cause like my, my
listening minutes are
like 105,000.
That's like 72
days of, of in a
year of listening to
Spotify. Um, and
like 460 genres,
it says can't
figure out anything.
Very cool. So, um,
do we get any
other movies or
television while I
scroll through trying
to find this is good
prep, trying to
find my predictions from
last year. Um, I
did not do my
homework.
Latest, latest,
latest, um, um,
critical role does
like have on, on
Amazon has like
animation, some
animation. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. And the
mighty nine, the
most recent one,
I didn't like the,
the, the, the
previous, these
Vox Machina,
what's it called?
Didn't really catch
me. Um, but the
latest, the mighty
nine was very
enjoyable. Um, even
though it like
suffers from this,
like everybody is
like PC, like
everybody has a
backstory and it's
like interesting.
All the main characters
are interesting.
And, uh, never mind.
It's that's the
format. It's fine.
But that was very
cool. Very
nice. Dungeons and
Dragons action
adventure.
Very cool. All
right. I found,
I found the
section of the
transcript of last
years where we had
some predictions and
most of these came
from Brent because
I, I don't have
some notes as well.
Oh, good. You're
okay. You might,
I should have just
deferred to you,
but one that
popped out here is,
uh, this has
got to be Brent
saying, this is Brent
saying this. He's
speaker too. He says,
I believe the
first major instance
of an LLM causing
human harm or safety
issues because its
controllers don't know
what the fuck they're
doing will occur in
2025. I was
offline. Did that
happen?
It already happened.
It already happened
like last year,
probably, but it
is already happening
in a, in a big,
on a big scale.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah. And I said,
I think unfortunately
you're right. We'll
see what happens.
So yeah, I think we,
I think I recall
some problems like
that. Uh, yeah.
If you want examples,
like the most, I guess,
the whole, um, like
the more, um, the,
the psychosis, like
AI psychosis, not
like in a, not, not,
not in these models,
but how they, the
parasocial relationship
between people and,
and these chatbots
is like a big health
issue. Then we see
like big, big studies
from, from consultants,
uh, having quotes
and, and, and citations
that, that don't exist,
et cetera. It's like
there's also already
being done. And my
prediction is that
there will be like,
um, loss of life
in the scale of like,
let's say, um, I don't
know, like, let's say
10,000 people die in
five years because
some kind of medicinal
genitis was not
caught or something
like that, right?
Sure. Yeah.
Something like that
is bound to happen.
I think that's a scary.
Next, next on your
list is like, uh, you
wanted to, to, to get
like Nicole on the
podcast. That was like,
Oh, I, I, every year
I want to get Nicole
forested onto the podcast.
And every, and this year
was weird because I took,
you know, four, five
months off, but, um,
always on the list.
I think she's, she
went from being, um,
like, uh, just
moderately famous to
being out of my reach
at this point. So we'll
see what I can do there.
Uh, another one is this
one's interesting. Um,
and again, uh, as much
as I joke about Brent
working at Sauti's
castle, um, haven't
really heard from him.
I've texted him a
few times and, um, I
hope he's doing well.
Uh, uh, but one, he
said, uh, blah, blah,
where was it at? He
says, he'll think it'll
become far more
politically correct to
force everyone back to
the office. And what
was interesting at the
time, Microsoft had
did that. You could
work from home. You
work from home. They
Brent always was
doing a podcast from
home. He had worked
from home. He went
into the office quite a
bit early on, but was
working from home more.
And then surprisingly
Microsoft asked people
to come back to the
office, um, you know,
end number of days a
week, I guess, three
days a week. And I'm
still like the whole
remote work thing. I
think works and I'm
going to go on a
little soap box here
because I don't know
if I did last year or
not, uh, managing
remote employees or
distributed workforce is
a different skill than
managing people in the
office. And this is
like another thing
where instead of giving
managers the education
they need to, uh, to,
to, um, manage those
folks effectively. Like
they refuse to do that.
We'll just force
people to come back.
We're looking at more
control. And yes, on
one hand, there are
some ways to get that
connection to happen.
You know, the leaders
are, Oh, how we've
got to get the
spontaneous communications
to happen. You can
do those. And Brent
and I talked about
this last year in
remote work. You can
do that. So I'm really
frustrated to see so
many companies demanding
folks get back to work.
And there's a lot of
conspiracy theorists,
whether they're
conspiracy theorists or
not saying that they're
doing this to get more
people to quit so they
don't have to do forced
layoffs. But I think
it's a mistake. Uh,
I, you know, in my
own job search, I'm
primarily looking for
remote work because I
believe it can work.
And I believe I know
how to manage a
remote team very well
at unity. I always
give the example at
unity. My team was
already in not
exaggerating 11
different countries,
maybe more. It was
no different when we
all went home because
all my meetings were on
zoom anyway. I didn't
have, and it's also
weirder to be in if
you're distributed to
be in a conference
room with five people
in the conference
room and five other
people on the screen
in different places.
It just, it's not
inclusive. I don't
think it's inclusive
when you have many
people in a conference
room because it's like
there's no empathy.
What you, I don't
know. I find it
weird. Like if everyone
is remote, they should
be everyone in a, in
a different meeting
room because there
is like this conversation
that happens in the
conference room that
you might lose if you
are just remote.
Yeah, I, yeah, it
frustrates me and I'm
looking for a remote
job in a leadership
position. I'm finding
folks wants people to
be able to come into
an office sometimes to
see people. But one
of the things I've
negotiated as well at
early stages of
interviews is I want
the ability to work
remotely, you know,
12 weeks a year. I
want to be able to go
work from wherever.
And I want the
team be able to do
that too. I want that
want the team to
support it. Who was
I talking to? Oh,
doesn't matter. The
company doesn't matter,
but they had their
globally distributed.
And sometimes people
do that or they're
remote. They say,
oh, we're remote and
they don't have a
budget for travel. I
would rather spend
that money on travel
than offices. And our
companies get screwed
up on the, on the
financials is, okay,
we're paying for the
office space. So we
can't pay for you to
travel, but we're
remote and you're just,
you're just not doing
it right. It just,
ah, so that hasn't. So
yes, we will be
seeing that. And
soon as Amazon with
Microsoft, we're
seeing more and more
companies ask people
to go back to work.
I don't think they're
getting what they
want out of that.
Soapbox, soapbox,
soapbox. One of the
things I brought up,
and this didn't happen.
This is my million
dollar idea was at
the time places like
we work as a lot of
in Capitol Hill,
where I live in
Seattle has like 10
different shared
working spaces. And
maybe if I got a
job that was remote,
I would get one just
get out of the house.
But the idea I had
last year, which did
not come true,
was that companies
should give you your
remote workers some
sort of, um, not a
stipend to do it.
I think my idea was
like a company
could buy some
credits and people
could just go use a
remote office anywhere
they wanted for those
credits. Um, I think
it's a great idea.
I'm again, I'm
not, I I'm probably
wrong because it
hasn't happened, but
I think what we have
today is a bunch of
coworking spaces
with a bunch of
empty desks and a
bunch of employees
who would like to
go work from some
place other than
their home remotely,
but not have a
good place to do it.
I think it's just it's
like like a gym
membership in a
company. I worked
here in Barcelona
when I joined,
I joined as a
remote worker,
but they had an
office here kind
of close to where I
live. I used to
go there every
now and then. Uh,
but after a while
they noticed that
not much people
were going to the
office and then
they closed it,
but they gave this
like this budget
that you could
spend on
coworking places
every now and then
if you wanted to.
And some people
used it. I find
it an interesting
idea and a fun
fact about remote
work since you're
talking about it.
Uh, I started a
new job like
three months ago,
more or less.
And before that
I was working on
my own for the
past two years and
I pretty much
appreciated the
previous episode
where you talked
to Lina about
finding the right
place that
is connected with
the things you
value and that
kind of stuff.
And before I
got to this
new job,
I was looking
for different positions
and, and I
found one that
was really interesting
because it was
in the tech stack
that I wanted in
the domain that
I wanted,
but I had to
go to the office
and I told
to myself,
you know what?
I'm, I'm
going to try it.
And I went to
the office the
first day
and I left the
company in the
second day
because I wasn't
ready.
I really,
I really
noticed how much.
Yeah, exactly.
Because then afterwards
I found a really
nice one where
I can work remotely.
There is a quite
nice office here
in Barcelona
in front of the
beach, which I can
go if I want to,
but I'm not
forced to.
And it was,
and it was not just
I was not just
prepared to go to the office,
but I was working
with people
from many of the people
they were from Germany
and also from
Switzerland,
I think,
and they were speaking
in German
in the office
between them.
And I felt so lost
that I told myself
that's not the right
place to me because
because I don't speak
German, right?
So it was,
it was funny because
yeah, I realized that
although many of
the other boxes checked,
this one didn't.
My remote work,
remote teams,
bucket list is what I want to try
is have some kind of
mob
working room,
remote,
like we know prep programming,
we know like mob programming,
where you get all in a room
on keyboard, on display,
you work on the same project,
on the same problem.
And I've not seen that yet
in any teams done
disciplined and like more often
in a remote setting
where there's some kind of,
let's say there's a team channel
that has an always online
voice and video feed
and you and whoever is like
driving currently
is sharing their screen
or there's some kind of
cloud workstation,
cloud first workstation
to do things
and have some kind of
round the clock
room, a room,
a virtual room
where people can come
to do more programming
like or work on a problem.
Problem is more like you
or like you said in last
some episode regarding
you may not even have to work
on the same project.
You can come together and work
in a way that you even work
on different things.
But main bucket list item
would be the mob
programming virtual room.
Yeah, I've had teams
that I've worked with
and others for just like
an ongoing huddle
in a Slack channel
where you could hang out
and it'd be like being
in the office together
like you're quietly working,
maybe on mute.
Then you unmute and say,
hey, does anybody know
how to blah, blah, blah?
And so I go, oh, yeah.
And just kind of recreate that.
These things can be done.
And looking through
my notes from last year,
we talked a lot about the fact
that we just haven't bothered
to teach folks how to manage
distributed or remote teams.
And it sucks.
And I think my only other
prediction was getting Nicole
Forsgren. I failed.
So that didn't work out.
But we did have our 200th
episode last year, which we
Brett and I carefully worked out
to make sure it was right
on our 10 year anniversary.
Everything went perfectly.
We did a couple like
three episodes in a week
once to kind of make
the numbers line up.
But it worked out great.
Had some guests on.
It was awesome.
So let's shift gear.
So a lot of looking back,
fun stuff.
I'm sure there's stuff
we missed, stuff
I was supposed to talk about,
stuff I plan to talk about.
I want to talk about
what's going to happen in 2026
or what we think
is going to happen.
And the easy one is
lots more with AI.
But what and what else
is going to happen?
What's going to change
in software?
in software quality?
What's going to change
maybe in the world in 2026?
Yeah, I was exactly going to
say that I think AI is
going to become even more central,
maybe not only in
software engineering,
but other aspects of life as well.
And because of that,
my prediction is quite of sad, actually,
because I think we will see more
layoffs coming up in the pipe
because of this
argumented intelligence
that is evolving.
And companies are
noticing that they can be
a lot more productive
with less people
by using AI.
And at the same time,
I think it's going to be even harder.
It's already harder for junior people
to start in their career.
It's going to become even harder
at the same time for senior people.
I think it's going to be
or you learn to use it
if you are not yet
or you are going to be discarded as well.
Yeah, I think I want to build
on that a little bit
and maybe talk about a prediction
that may not come through in 2026.
So one, you're absolutely correct.
There are universities now
that are beginning to scrap
their CS departments
because they don't want to create,
train people,
give people the education,
do a job that doesn't exist.
So again, a university
is not a vocational school.
We won't go into that one there.
You're absolutely right
in that existing companies today
are seeing advantages
with AI and improving productivity
where they don't need as many people.
However, I think I said this last year,
maybe even the year before,
what Gen.A.I.
has done and is doing
in some cases for us
finally is generating new businesses.
I do not believe
that all the innovation
that can possibly happen
with software has already occurred.
And then we just need
fewer people to do what exists.
What is going to happen,
maybe not in 2026,
but in the coming years is
new businesses are going to come up
with new innovation
with things we didn't even
think about doing before
because it was just it was unfeasible
that can now be done with AI.
An example is
I'm on an advisory board
for a couple of companies
that are using agentic AI
to solve very specific problems.
And this is a much better
like I look at GPT
or all these things is like
AI is the average of the Internet.
They're trained on everything.
So they give you a nice little average.
They're good.
People use.
I think people use chat
GPT very inefficiently a lot.
It's just it's a search engine
where you can use real text
and it guesses for you.
But I think with a real
interesting things happen
when you take AI agents
for agentic AI
and train them on specific problems
and use them to solve problems
that were unsolvable before.
You know, the canonical example is
pick your logging system.
People always log way too much
and people and humans go
and try and find that out.
Or, you know, five years ago,
they use ML to try
and find some insights.
Having these AI agents
is a way to solve that problem.
There are some
there are some opportunities
for testing tools as well.
But if you get that agent
to act like a specific kind of tester
trained on very specific
curated information
versus the average of,
you know, 10,000 books on testing,
which all contradict each other.
There's a story I tell.
I read my first book
on software testing.
I thought I knew a lot.
I read my second testing.
I was confused.
And my third book,
I began to see the conflicts
in ideas, ideologies
and philosophies and for my own opinions.
I think the the LLMs
have that same problem
if you don't curate those.
If you're trying to solve
a very specific problem
and you can train your AI
on an LLM based on a large
and it's a large set of data.
So it's not just ML,
but you're doing that
to solve a specific problem
using curated data to train that model.
There's some really interesting problems
that can be solved.
And those are just the easy ones.
I have to believe
that there are problems
that we have ignored
or haven't even thought about
because they've been deemed impossible
that can be solved through
agentic AI or something,
something gen AI equivalent
that we just haven't done yet
because I guess my main point is
you're absolutely right
that companies don't need as many people
because they're more productive.
I cannot believe that we've invented
everything we can in software
and there aren't jobs
for people to go invent those
to go help curate those new products
and bring them to market.
I don't I don't really think
it's about software like automation.
It's about when you when you do automation,
right, you automate the boring parts
so people can be creative.
Yes.
And the main innovation
I see is not coming.
Maybe software in terms of better
specialized, smaller,
more scalable models
and maybe different architectures
or algorithms, paradigms,
how these agents interact.
But the most interesting stuff,
I think, will be coming from
or is coming right now
or still in the pipeline
even before AI.
What's coming right now is before AI still.
It's not that AI is not applied yet
to the things that are coming
in material science and medicine
and these kind of things.
Yes.
And I'm very looking forward
to what's coming there.
Like I'm still like 10 percent
hoping for sci-fi, though
I think I still think
things will be much more boring.
But in terms of the
predictions in gen.ai,
what we will see is
waves of massive adaptive.
We're already seeing that, I think.
Massive waves of self-adapting
forms and viruses,
like scouring the internet
for personal information
with learning and models
learning on the fly or whatever.
But I don't think we will reach
this kind of recursive
self-improvement,
HCI, ASI, Singularity, AI God.
This will not happen.
But we will see more things
being shit with AI
and but also like successful
forms and successful applications.
Yeah, and I just wanted to mention
I absolutely agree with what
Alan said that
AI is going to create
lots of businesses
that don't exist yet.
And this is why when I said
that maybe it's going to become
central part not only of
software engineering,
but other industries as well.
This is what I was mentioning.
It's not just in software
engineering, many other jobs
that nowadays depend on people
to do the boring part of the work.
They may be replaced by AI as well.
And this is what makes me
sad that as we saw
layoffs in the tech industry,
we may see layoffs
in other industries as well,
which is going to create
new jobs, new roles,
which will require different skills.
But still, we might see
this impact in other
industries as well.
Cool. Yeah, I yeah.
We're we're all in agreement here.
And a lot of the arguments are
I mean, I want to call them arguments.
The fears around AI
are very similar to what we're
hearing with test automation
in the past, even industrial
automation before then.
I remember hearing 20 years ago
someone complaining on
some radio station back to
the radio station still exist.
I'm sure they do.
About how the the the Amazon,
the robots at Amazon
are going to take away jobs.
And like, yeah,
but it makes more jobs as well.
So other than AI,
this might be a difficult
question in 2025 to ask.
Other than AI,
what's going to change in 2026?
And you can add your thought
to what I'm looking forward to,
because it's like sci-fi
and I guess it's wishful thinking
since I was a child is like
I think in this year
it will be able to be.
I will be able to use like
brain computer interfaces
to replace my mouse and keyboard
with something like gesture
and mind control to
the same effectiveness
as mouse and keyboard.
That's my prediction
that you get like consumer items.
Like let's say under $2,000
next Christmas under $2,000.
You get like a Bluetooth
keyboard and mouse,
but it's basically mind control
and working with your
gestures and stuff.
Hmm. All right.
Like it.
Anything else?
Well, talking about
a different thing
other than AI,
I think like since we talked
about the investments
a little bit before,
I think finance is going
to change as well, like
in terms of like
the big players
noticing more cryptocurrency,
especially Bitcoin,
which in my opinion
is the one that has
all the properties
that is scarce.
It's limited and it's like
not governed by one country
or anything.
I think maybe big players
will start noticing it more.
They are already,
but I think it's going to become
part of like the
the assets that, you know,
normal people can invest.
And we also see like states,
states interested in these states
investing in these kinds of stock
piles of digital currencies.
Yeah.
Yeah, cool.
I predict and this is funny
because I talk about this a lot.
I am looking for a job
and look at what it says.
I was going to predict
that I was going to get a job
this year, but I have a win
win situation going on here.
I'm probably going to get a job
and I'm going to be,
as I've discussed,
I'm very selective.
I'm going to get a job
that fits everything
I'm looking for.
And I am not.
I am like Valmer.
I am prepared to walk out
of that job on day two.
If I get there and I realize I wasn't
wasn't what I was ready for.
So but the win win is
not a prediction.
One of the two will happen.
I am either going to be working
in the next several months
or if I don't have a job
by the end of June
for some reason,
and it could be good reasons
because I'm picky.
I am going to go hike
the Colorado Trail,
about four hundred and thirty miles.
What is that?
Like eight hundred kilometers
this summer.
So it's win win.
I get it.
I'll have a job I love
or I'll get to go outside
in nature where I love.
And it's that I that's not even
that's a guarantee.
I will.
One of those two will happen.
So good luck.
I pretty much like the last episode
because when I when I was looking
for a job, I'm very picky as well.
Good for you.
I like selective more than picky,
but it's fine. I get it.
Yeah.
And one thing that I I did
in two of my previous jobs,
which I have already mentioned
to my manager here in Spain,
you have six months
of probation period.
And in other countries,
I work there with you.
In one of them,
it was one month
and the other one was three months.
And I used to use this time
not only for the company
to see if I was really
the person they were looking
for, but also for me to see
if the company was exactly
what I was looking for.
So I used to use this
this time to really
decide if I would want to continue
or not in the company
and make kind of an agreement
with my manager saying,
this is what you can expect from me.
This is what I expect from you.
Are we aligned?
Are we not?
Should we align before?
Because if we are not aligned,
the probation period,
I might leave before the probation period ends.
And you should.
Exactly.
I'm going to do my best
on this job search to clarify
all that before I start.
Yeah, but sometimes you have to start
because sometimes people tell you
things that may not be true.
Exactly.
When they want you,
they will tell you everything
that you want to hear.
Yeah, I'm aware.
I'm aware.
And I want to be extreme.
I say the whole hiring process is broken.
You just pick the first person
who arrives and then you put them
on this two month probation
and you will see within a week
or two if you're fit or not.
And all that after two months,
after two months, it should be clear.
So the whole interview process is skipped
and you just do like probation two months.
It would be great if there was not even that long.
I love probationary and like,
you seem like a pretty good fit.
And that's like,
and you could get fired or leave
your choice after one day
or after, you know,
and eventually you get a contract.
Like when I first started at Microsoft,
I was a contract employee.
I was a contract employee for five months.
I got hired full time.
I liked the whole idea of try before you buy
on both sides.
And I think, you know,
there was still an interview process,
but it wasn't, I guess it was a lot,
but the whole interview process is about like,
it's about like minimizing your risk
and finding the right candidate
that you think that will make it five years
or whatever in your company,
but you can get the same results,
much cheaper, more or less,
by doing just, hey, come work with us.
You only know if the person can work with you,
if they work with you.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, and yeah, interviews are weird.
One prediction is like,
you're talking about win-win.
I will predict that Brent will not be back next year
to do an episode about stoicism.
You were saying you want to do an episode about stoicism.
So if I'm right,
I will be here next year
for the end of your episode and say, I'm right.
If I'm wrong, then Brent will be here
and we'll have done an episode on stoicism.
Yeah.
I got a follow-up with Brent as he was even listening.
So yeah, something will happen there.
Something will happen.
We'll keep the A-B testings,
because I need a place to vent and tell my stories
and get on my soap boxes.
So I'll keep it going with guests as we go.
And that's a prediction.
The A-B testing podcast will continue.
It's going to be, I don't know.
I'm tempted to record a whole new intro
until Brent's back.
But I'm not going to make a prediction there.
Should I?
No, because I'll just make it a goal.
Anyway, I don't know what's going to happen.
Any other predictions before we close for today?
All right.
So this was a little bit of a fun,
a lot of fun reflection, looking forward,
et cetera podcast.
I want to thank both of you so much,
Vollmer and Global Forming for being
our almost permanent guest host.
And thanks for being on today and sharing your thoughts.
It was really cool to hear
all the financial information,
the thoughts around AI, the job stuff.
I think Vollmer, you and I align on a lot of things.
So it's really cool.
All right.
Any other final words from either of you
before we call it a day?
Just wanted to thank you for having us.
No, just wanted to thank you for having us.
I wish a awesome 2026, whatever comes,
if it's a new job or the hike,
I'm pretty sure you're going to have fun.
Yeah, that's my goal.
I'm going to have fun no matter what.
Yeah, same.
Best wishes for next year and get a good hike, et cetera.
All right.
Well, thank you both.
I'm Spy.
And this has been Vollmer and Global Forming
on episode 234 of the AAB Testing Podcast.